.
* Gackern *
* Drollige Musik *
* Scheppern *
Geht man mit Kollegen essen
und kommt das Thema Ernährung
auf den Tisch,
geht man besser an die Bar,
weil die sich gleich
die Köpfe einschlagen.
Wir müssen essen.
* Drollige Musik, Stimmengewirr *
Auch relativ viel.
* Drollige Musik *
Wir erleben im Früchte- und Gemüse-
bereich eine Goldgräberstimmung.
Und die Frage,
die sich heute stellt:
"Was soll ich heute bloss essen?"
* Grunzen *
Wir haben Dampfbrötchen
mit Herz und Zunge vom Rind.
Dazu Pate vom Schwein
mit Gelée vom Schwein.
Mmh!
- Sie sagte, das sei Gans.
Es ist süsslich und sauer.
Was darf ich heute bloss essen?
Ich befasste mich mit der
Milchindustrie, die mich anwiderte.
Kalbfleisch stammt von einem
ermordeten Baby der Milchindustrie.
Was darf ich heute
bloss nicht essen?
Wir können uns das ganze Jahr
hindurch gesund ernähren,
ohne dass ich dieser Dame das Leben
nehmen, den Kopf abschneiden muss.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Der vegane Lebensstil
zieht sich viel weiter.
Es geht nicht nur um die Ernährung.
In dieser Bewegung gibt es
auch Hypes, die Leute drehen durch.
Es geht nur noch um Ernährung,
es wird zu einer Art Religion.
* Beschwingte Musik *
(Clopath) Es ist etwas Schönes,
etwas Lässiges.
Es bringt die Gesellschaft zusammen.
Ich möchte den Wert des Essens
unter die Leute bringen.
* Beschwingte Musik *
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Muhen *
* Klick-Klack der Melkmaschine *
* Sanftes Bimmeln *
* Surren *
* Klavierklänge *
Es sind
die letzten ruhigen Minuten des Tages
für den Gemüse- und Früchtehändler
Tiziano Marinello.
Guten Morgen!
Du siehst, es sind schöne Rosetten.
Einfach etwas gross,
aber geschmacklich mega.
V.a. innen.
- Es ist mega.
Merci.
- Mach's gut. Tschau.
Tschüss, Doris!
Marinello
ist einer der grösseren Händler hier.
Der Engrosmarkt Zürich.
Das ist lässig.
Jetzt ist Traubensaison.
Jetzt sind sie gut.
Sie haben Zuckerflecken
und sind nicht mehr so schön,
aber das macht Spass.
Mhm. Super.
Es sind Produzenten aus der Schweiz,
aber auch Importeure,
die hier ihre Waren anbieten:
800 t im Wert von über 1 Mio. Fr.
Nacht für Nacht.
Salü, Dani.
Guten Morgen miteinander!
Guten Morgen.
Tschau, Detlef.
Gemüsehändler jammern gern.
Aber wer jetzt jammert,
der macht seinen Job nicht richtig.
Es gibt einen Wechsel:
weg vom Fleisch,
hin zu mehr Früchten und Gemüse.
Das muss man auch verkaufen.
Man kann nicht nur
die Tomate verkaufen.
Man muss auch sagen, woher sie
kommt, wer sie produziert hat.
Was unterscheidet diese Tomate
von einer anderen Tomate?
Man muss Emotionen reinbringen.
Die Tomate ist der Star
auf dem Teller, nicht das Fleisch.
Das macht uns Spass.
Aus der Gastronomie
kommen mehr Fragen zu uns,
was wir früher nicht hatten.
Die Leute interessieren sich
für Sorten,
alte Sorten, neue Geschichten.
Tiziano Marinello
hat den Familienbetrieb
vor einigen Jahren
von seinem Vater übernommen.
Hoi, Susanne. Tschau.
Die Firma beliefert
hauptsächlich die Gastronomie,
von Kantinen bis zu Luxushäusern.
Ja, okay. Ich bräuchte noch etwas.
Ja, ja, irgendwann
werden wir uns finden.
Zu seinem frühmorgendlichen Rundgang
gehört auch,
das Angebot der anderen
im Auge zu behalten.
Das sind wunderschöne,
buttrige Birnen.
Etwas überreif,
für die Gastronomie zu reif.
Aber so zum Essen - lässig.
Jeden Morgen läuft man
an etwas ran und fragt ...
Der Importeur weiss es auch nicht,
der Produzent am Ende auch nicht.
"Es ist irgendein Baum."
Das ist z.T. lustig.
Du, was ist das, neben den Kaiser?
Das sind Commis.
- Das sind Commis? Ah, genau.
Ständig auf der Suche nach Neuem,
das er seinen Kunden anbieten könnte.
Der Detailhandel schaut stark,
was der Gastronom macht.
Zurzeit ist der Koch
der neue Popstar.
Man schaut, wohin sie sich bewegen.
Das wird dann
für den Privathaushalt übernommen.
Es geht eher in diese Richtung.
Ernährungstrends
kommen vielfach aus der Gastronomie.
* Muhen, Kuhglocken,
sanftes Bimmeln *
Schamserberg, Graubünden,
auf fast 2'000 m Höhe.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Wachholderbeeren sammeln
mit Rebecca Clopath.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Hier hat es auch ordentlich ...
Wobei, einige von ihnen sind
schon faul. Die lassen wir sein.
Sie ist eine angesagte Köchin und
trifft offenbar den Nerv der Zeit.
Sie kreiert sog. Esswahrnehmungen.
Als lokales Gewürz haben wir sie
immer wieder auf dem Menü.
Für diese Esswahrnehmung
haben wir sie in einer Gewürzwurst -
die Wurst besteht
aus Murmeltier- und Gamsfleisch.
Wir servieren sie mit einer ge-
schmorten Karotte und Karottensamen.
Hier hat es ordentlich. Schau, da.
Wenn ich hier draussen bin
und die Produkte frisch ernte,
dann merke ich,
dass unser Treibstoff,
das, was wir zu uns nehmen,
auch ein Teil der Natur ist.
Das möchte ich gerne wiedergeben
und den Leuten auch wieder zeigen,
v.a. die Vielfalt
des alpinen Raums ...
Ich möchte aufzeigen,
dass sie da ist,
und man dadurch evtl.
eine andere Aufmerksamkeit bekommt,
wenn man das nächste Mal
auf einen Berg steigt.
# Ti-ti-ti-ri-ti-ti.
Ja, sag nichts.
But they're perfect like that.
Wir sind hier am ...
Wir sammeln Blaubeerblätter.
Es hat noch ein paar Blaubeeren
dran, ein paar Überbleibsel.
Das ist eigentlich ...
Vor drei Jahren
haben wir einmal Tee gemacht -
aus geröstetem Buchweizen
und diesen Blättern.
Er schmeckt wie
ein japanischer Reis- und Grüntee.
Es ist sehr spannend
und das möchte ich den Leuten
als Giveaway mitgeben.
Mit den beiden Köchen
Ruben Sägesser und Aziade Cirlini
setzt sie ihre Ideen um.
They've much more pepper flavor.
The greens?
- Yes.
So.
Schön. Megaschön.
Wir haben in diesem Jahr neun
verschiedene Sorten angepflanzt.
Ich freue mich schon sehr,
sie im Winter im Restaurant
servieren zu können.
Raclette vom Feuerring
mit Kartoffeln.
Es sind kleine Mengen,
die wir hier machen.
Da würde jeder sagen,
das sei totaler Unsinn.
Nicht jeder, aber es gibt genug,
die das sagen.
Für uns ist es sehr wertvoll,
wir möchten damit arbeiten.
So.
* Sphärische Klänge,
sanftes Bimmeln *
Mir ist es wichtig,
dass ich den Baum nicht verletze.
Das ist sehr lecker.
Die zitronige Note kann man gut für
ein Eis oder eine Creme brauchen.
Bei Outdoor-Workshops
mache ich gern ...
Man kennt immer die Vanillecreme
zum Schluss.
Wir machen eine Fichtenharzcreme.
Das ist lässig, weil sie schöne,
unerwartete Aromen mit sich bringt.
* Sphärische Klänge *
* Akzentuierte Gitarrenakkorde *
Essen ist auch ein spannendes Thema
im Zusammenhang mit Wissenschaft.
Viele Menschen interessieren sich
für neue Erkenntnisse
und Foodtrends.
Christine Brombach ist Professorin
für Ernährungswissenschaften
und eine gefragte Expertin.
Talk bei TV Liechtenstein.
So geht's, oder?
Kamera 3.
Dann fangen wir an.
Grüss Gott
zu "Liechtenstein Live Talk".
Heutiges Thema ist die Ernährung.
Frau Prof. Dr. Christine Brombach,
essen wir, was uns schmeckt
oder schmeckt uns, was wir essen?
Geschmack ist erlernt.
Geschmack ist kulturell erlernt.
Wir werden eigentlich
mit einer Präferenz
für verschiedene
Geschmacksrichtungen geboren.
Christine Brombach lebt in Wädenswil.
Sie arbeitet dort als Dozentin
an der Hochschule
für angewandte Wissenschaften
und ist in verschiedenen Fachgremien
im In- und Ausland.
* Hüpfende Klänge *
Nächster Termin: Vortrag in Schaan.
Erwartet wird auch
Bestsellerautor Bas Kast.
Vom "Ernährungskompass" wurden bisher
800'000 Exemplare verkauft.
Ein Überraschungserfolg.
Kast schrieb das Buch
nach einer gesundheitlichen Krise.
Er hat v.a. wissenschaftliche
Ernährungsstudien ausgewertet.
Als Autor schreibt man ein Exposée,
das sind etwa 20 Seiten,
worum es im Buch gehen soll.
Das habe ich
meinem Verlag angeboten.
Der sagte spontan: "Das können Sie
vielleicht schreiben, Herr Kast,
aber wir können es nicht verkaufen."
Es wurde von mehreren Verlagen
erst einmal abgelehnt.
Entsprechend niedrig
waren meine Erwartungen.
Ich wollte es unbedingt schreiben,
weil ich mich besser gefühlt habe
und ich Feuer gefangen hatte
mit dem Thema.
Ich dachte auch,
dass es okay sein wird,
aber dass es so ein Erfolg wird,
wusste keiner.
Ernährung ist das Thema der Stunde.
Es füllt Säle. Landauf, landab.
Danke schön.
Jeder von uns verspeist pro Jahr
1,5 t Lebensmittel.
Wir werden in Zukunft viele Menschen
auf der Welt haben - 10 Mrd. -
die alle ungefähr im Schnitt
1,5 Mio. t pro Jahr verbrauchen.
Damit müssen sie Ressourcen
in Anspruch nehmen,
um diese Nahrung überhaupt
erst zu produzieren.
Nicht erst seit Greta wissen wir,
dass die Ernährungsweise
rund einen Drittel aller Emissionen
mit verursacht.
Jetzt geht es um das Schicksal
des Planeten, das ist heftig.
Da ist ein kleiner konkreter Teller.
Eigentlich will man einfach nur
satt werden und es auch geniessen.
Plötzlich
kommt eine Dimension hinzu,
die es nie in der Geschichte
der Menschheit gab.
"Wie geht es dem Planeten insgesamt,
wenn ich das jetzt esse?"
"Das Steak versus der Linsensuppe."
Essen ist heute
sehr viel mehr als nur Ernährung.
Essen ist für viele
identitätsstiftend.
Es ist Teil der Selbstdarstellung.
Schauen Sie sich bestimmte
Influenzer oder YouTuber an.
"Sag mi,r was du isst,
und ich sage dir, wer du bist."
Woher wissen Sie,
dass jemand Veganer ist?
Er sagt es Ihnen gleich.
Von daher: essen -
dazugehören oder abgrenzen.
Die Frage, die sich heute stellt:
"Was soll ich heute bloss essen?"
Als Mann ist man ...
Ich bin etwas hilflos, wenn ich in
ein Verkaufsgeschäft gehen sollte.
Ich weiss kaum,
was ich wirklich einkaufen soll.
Frauen beschäftigen sich mehr
mit dem Thema als Männer.
Man sieht es auch am Publikum.
Es sind mehr Frauen als Männer da.
Wenn ich Fast Food esse,
liegt es mir mehr auf dem Magen,
als wenn ich Gemüse
und Früchte esse.
Es ist mir schon sehr wichtig.
Regional und bio,
aber zwischendurch esse ich auch
Schokolade. Kuchen ...
Darf man keine Schokolade essen?
- Na ja, es ist ...
Manchmal ist es zu viel.
Ich esse verdammt wenig Gemüse.
Ja, wenig ...
Es ist mir nicht recht,
aber ich mag es einfach nicht.
Pommes frites - für mich
gibt es keine Pommes frites.
Das gibt es nicht -
und Chips auch nicht. Zu ölig.
Es ist schon noch
eine gewisse Verunsicherung da.
Es ist interessant,
Vorträge zu besuchen
oder auf Social Media,
Instagram und so.
Es war einfach normal,
dass ich morgens den Tag mit
Schokolade und Kaffee begonnen habe.
Mittags beim Schreiben
hatte ich keine Zeit.
Dann sass ich da und riss
eine Packung Schinken oder so auf
und spülte mit Kaffee runter.
Ich hielt mich für fit,
bis ich eines Tages losjoggte.
Nach nicht einmal 1 km
musste ich mit einem massiven Stich
in der Brust stehen bleiben.
Das war wirklich
kein Stehenbleiben im Sinne von:
"Es wäre gut, wenn ich mal eine
kurze Verschnaufpause einlege."
Nein, mein Körper zwang mich,
stehen zu bleiben.
Das war wirklich in der Art -
ich habe es im Buch beschrieben:
Eine stählerne Hand packte mein Herz
und drückte es ruckartig zusammen.
Ich stand da und hoffte,
dass ich davonkomme.
Ab dem Moment habe ich
eigentlich nur das getan,
was ich zu dem Zeitpunkt
schon seit 15 Jahren tat:
Als Wissenschaftsjournalist
ergründete ich dieses Thema.
250 ernährungsrelevante Studien
seien damals erschienen - täglich.
Für sein Buch
hat er sich darin vertieft.
Wenn man
von der Motivation herkommt,
interessiert man sich nicht mehr
unbedingt für Ideologien.
Lowcarb, vegan oder vegetarisch
stehen nicht mehr im Zentrum.
Man will einfach wissen,
wie man sich selbst heilen kann
oder was man seinem Körper
Gutes tun kann -
jenseits von diesen Schlagwörtern.
Das war mein Anliegen
und das war sehr motivierend.
Sie müssen nicht mir glauben.
Sie können es selbst
an Ihrem Körper ausprobieren.
Wenn Sie Beschwerden haben,
von denen Sie denken,
dass die Ernährung oder das Fasten
etwas ausrichten könnte,
geben Sie Ihrem Körper mal
drei Wochen und schauen Sie,
ob es bei Ihnen
etwas Positives bewirkt.
Ich werde immer wieder gefragt:
"Frau Brombach, was kann ich tun?"
Dann antworte ich:
"Wenn Sie etwas auf den Teller tun,
sollte die Hälfte
pflanzliche Produkte sein."
"Ein Viertel die Eiweisskomponente
und ein Viertel
die Stärkekomponente."
Packt man das zusammen,
hat man eigentlich
schon ganz viel gewonnen.
* Fröhliches Stimmengewirr *
Im digitalen Zeitalter ist Essen
zunehmend ein globales
und politisches Handlungsfeld.
Und das ist alles das, was sich
auf unserem Teller abspielt.
Ob ich es will oder nicht -
es ist immer mit dabei.
* Stimmengewirr *
* Lockere Gitarrenklänge *
Wir machen heute mal wieder Fajitas.
Das ist bei uns beliebt
und kommt bei den Kindern super an.
Und, äh, ja ...
Wir machen nicht
die klassischen Fajitas.
Meine Frau macht
zwei verschiedene Hummussorten.
Ein klassisches Hummus
aus Kichererbsen.
Wir verändern es
nach unserem eigenen Rezept,
mit Sojajoghurt oder Sojamilch.
Wir brauchen Gewürze,
die uns schmecken.
Wir machen noch eines
mit Randensaft.
Das schmeckt etwas süsslicher.
Wir haben geräucherten Tofu,
geschnetzelte Zwiebeln
und für die Kinder haben
wir Knusperschnitzel gekauft.
Und, ähm ...
- Nur für die Kinder?
Vielleicht esse ich
auch ein bisschen.
Das ist nicht Standard, wir kaufen
selten Fleischersatzprodukte.
Tofu ist das höchste der Gefühle.
Die Kinder essen das alles?
- Alles.
Auch Federkohl?
Also ...
Es braucht manchmal schon ...
... etwas Überzeugungsarbeit.
Wir machen ein Spiel daraus
oder wir erklären einfach,
warum es gesund ist.
Man muss etwas kreativ sein.
Man schmuggelt Sprossen
in einen Wrap.
Stelle ich ein Schüssel
mit Sprossen hin,
hält sich die Begeisterung
in Grenzen.
Aber eingepackt in einen Wrap
oder in ein Sandwich,
dann mögen sie es sehr.
Seit drei Jahren leben sie vegan.
Sport ist wichtig für beide.
Er ist dreifacher Schweizer
Karatemeister und gelernter Koch.
Veganismus wird oft
mit Verzicht verbunden.
Ich fühlte mich dermassen angewidert
von alldem, was nötig ist,
um tierische Produkte herzustellen.
Ich wollte das machen. Es war mir
egal, wie schwierig es ist
und wie viel ich verzichten muss.
Und dann war es so einfach!
Ich lernte so viele neue Lebens-
mittel und Zubereitungsarten kennen.
Früher konnte man mich
mit einem Linsen-Bohneneintopf
nicht begeistern.
Wir würzen den so lecker
mit geräuchertem Paprika,
mit Knoblauch, mit Kräutern und so.
Ich gebe Ihnen gern einen Bissen
zum Versuchen und Sie werden sagen,
dass es einer der besten Fajitas
ist, die Sie je gegessen haben -
ohne jetzt anzugeben.
Sie wollen mich bekehren.
- Ja, ich missioniere total.
Sie wollen auch andere bekehren.
- Das ist so, ja.
Sie sind missionarisch unterwegs.
- Nicht nur etwas.
Schauen Sie ...
Ich bin überzeugt davon,
dass unsere Gesellschaft
kein Problem an Nährstoffmangel hat,
sondern an Mangel von Mitgefühl.
Diese Lebensweise beinhaltet,
dass man gewisse Werte,
Mitgefühl für andere Lebewesen
einfach zu Ende denkt.
Zumindest die meisten von uns
sind gegen Unterdrückung von Frauen,
gegen Sexismus, gegen Rassismus,
gegen Ausbeutung der Schwächeren,
aber auf dem Teller
hört das nicht auf.
Mit dem Teller können wir
ein Statement abgeben,
ob wir das mit der Ausbeutung
zu Ende gedacht haben.
* Lockere Gitarrenklänge *
Als Nahrungsergänzung
erhalten die Kinder Vitamin B 12.
Magst du es nicht?- Doch.
* Thomas Sigrist lacht. *
Jeder einzelne,
der tierische Produkte reduziert
oder ganz damit aufhört,
trägt sehr viel dazu bei.
Ich bin nicht ganz so aktiv
unterwegs wie mein Mann,
was Veganismus betrifft.
Trotzdem haben schon sehr viele
in meinem Umfeld massiv reduziert.
Das Bewusstsein, ja.
Auch gesundheitlich.
Ich merke da auch ...
... einen massiven Unterschied.
Nicht nur die Gesundheit,
auch meine Seele ...
Es ist einfach so schön,
wenn man sagen kann,
dass man nicht mehr
Teil des Ganzen ist,
wenn man nichts mehr
damit zu tun hat
und auch nichts mehr
damit zu tun haben will.
Das ist einfach schön.
Die Suche
nach der richtigen Ernährung
sorgt im Buchhandel
für Millionenumsätze.
Immer mehr Menschen
verändern ihre Ernährung.
Der Fleischkonsum in der Schweiz
beispielsweise
sinkt laut Bundesamt für Statistik
leicht.
* Temperamentvolle Musik *
Und fast täglich begegnet Leserinnen
und Lesern das Thema -
mit verschiedensten Aussagen.
Es gehört dazu, dass man sich
so darüber informiert,
was auf dem Markt läuft.
Über Insta oder Facebook
ist es lässig.
Man kann jeden Morgen zeigen, was es
gerade neu auf dem Markt gibt,
was man lässig findet.
Es ist ein steter Flow an News,
den man bringen kann.
Scharfe Geschichte.
Erfrischend.- Die Leute mögen sie
lieber als die anderen.
Ich esse seit Monaten
deutlich weniger Fleisch.
Ich brauchte sehr lange
für dieses Umdenken.
Ich habe das nicht
aus Idealismus gemacht.
Ich bin kein Heiliger. Ich habe
gemerkt, dass es mir guttut.
Ich esse immer noch alles.
Ich achte vermehrt darauf.
Ich habe zu Hause z.B. keine Milch
und kein Fleisch mehr.
Aber wenn im Restaurant ein gutes
Stück auf dem Big Green Egg liegt,
dann esse ich das.
Damit habe ich kein Problem.
Für mich selbst schaue ich,
dass es einfach weniger wird.
Ich esse noch halb so viel Fleisch
wie früher.
* Temperamentvolle Musik *
Für mich war das früher
immer schrecklich.
Meine Mutter
gab mir solche Boxen mit.
Ich gab sie meinen Kindern mit, die
das irgendwann richtig doof fanden.
Mittlerweile schätzen sie das,
was ich auch versuche.
Zum einen hab ich da drin,
was ich will
und bin in gewisser Weise autark.
Ich werde nicht ständig provoziert:
"Kauf mich, iss mich!"
* Treibende Musik *
Das ist so
wie ein absoluter Widerspruch.
Nämlich:
Die Menschen auf der Strasse ...
Dieses Mampfen, dieses Fressen,
dieses ständige Grazing -
wie die Kühe - laufend essen
steht im Widerspruch.
Man stopft sich irgendwas hinein,
weil es gerade passt.
Oder weil man gerade angeregt wurde,
weil es gut riecht und gut aussieht.
Es ist für mich
eine Paradoxie unserer Moderne.
Einerseits sagt man: "Okay, da nehme
ich mir die Zeit, da geniesse ich,
da zelebriere ich."
Und sonst muss es irgendwie
eating-on-the-go sein.
* Kuhglocken, Muhen *
* Kristallene sphärische Klänge *
Mmh, das ist so gut. Mmh.
Der schmeckt nach Blauschimmel.
Geil.
* Rebecca Clopath lacht. *
Im Bündner Bergdorf Lohn
betreibt Rebecca Clopath
ein kleines Restaurant
mit nur zwölf Plätzen.
Hier bewirtet sie mit kleinen,
saisonalen Mittagsmenüs ihre Gäste.
Höhepunkt
sind ihre Esswahrnehmungen,
die im Frühling und Herbst
stattfinden
und auf die sie sich jeweils
monatelang vorbereitet.
And then we can check the top.
* Bimmeln *
* Sphärische Klänge *
Ich kam nie über die Schweiz hinaus,
obwohl ich gerne gereist wäre.
Schlussendlich
habe ich für mich selbst gemerkt:
"Wenn ich mich hier vertiefe,
kann ich auch auf Reisen gehen."
Ich kann viele
neue Geschichten finden,
so viele neue Geschmäcker -
gerade in unmittelbarer Nähe -
die mich einfach faszinieren.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Wenn ich das ernte,
ernte ich das
mit einem anderen Bewusstsein,
als wenn ich eine fixfertige,
saubere Kiste mit Gemüse habe,
zu der ich keinen Bezug habe.
Das ist das Schöne für mich.
So kann ich das Produkt
anders verarbeiten
und es dem Gast anders vermitteln.
Dem Ganzen Zeit geben, ruhen lassen.
Super. Tipptopp.
Der Geschmack, der dann im Lauch,
im Blumenkohl, in der Pastinake
oder auch im Wirz ist,
ist dann so saftig
und so puristisch.
Das ist so gut zu essen.
* Knistern *
Das ist ein Test,
den lassen wir mal.
Weil ich frischen Salat nicht mag,
lege ich ihn auf den Feuerring.
* Lachen *
Das schlimmste Erlebnis hatte ich,
als ich in einem Hotel anfing
und 600 Pouletbrüstchen
anbraten musste. So schnell.
Ich hatte
nur eine halbe Stunde Zeit.
Ich dachte:
"Vor mir liegen einfach 300 Hühner,
"also nur ein kleiner Teil davon."
Ich hab sie einfach angebraten.
Ohne irgendein Bewusstsein,
ohne Freude, ohne ...
Ohne zu schauen,
was es wirklich einmal war.
Das hat mich ziemlich ... Wäh!
Ich war froh,
konnte ich nach dem Mittag raus
und musste nie mehr rein.
Das reichte schon.
In Lohn
leben mehr Tiere als Menschen.
Die Gemeinde hat nur 53 Einwohner.
Vor fast 30 Jahren haben alle sechs
Bauernbetriebe auf Bio umgestellt.
Die Bergbauern leben
von den Direktzahlungen des Bundes
und vom Verkauf des Biofleischs
und anderen Produkten.
* Muhen *
Kürzlich ist auf dem Hof
von Rebecca Clopaths Eltern
eine junge Familie dazugekommen.
Leonie von Arx und Dominique Schmutz,
beide Industriedesigner,
haben ihrem urbanen Leben
den Rücken gekehrt.
Hallo.
Hoi.
Vorsichtig.
Dominique Schmutz
hat sich zum Landwirt weitergebildet.
Er wird den Hof von
Rebecca Clopaths Eltern weiterführen.
Die Überzeugung kam,
weil ich merkte,
dass das, was ich machte
für mich nicht befriedigend
oder in meinen Augen
nicht relevant war.
Ich wollte dem Ursprung näher sein,
näher auch an der Produktion.
Etwas tun, worin man
den Sinn dahinter sieht.
Ein sinnvolle Arbeit.
Zuletzt arbeitete ich
als Gestalter im Luxussektor.
Dementsprechend
tauchte bei mir die Frage auf
und ich fand keine Antwort darauf.
Hier finde ich die Antwort.
Ich finde es
eine sinnvolle Tätigkeit,
einen sinnvollen Beruf -
und schön ist er natürlich auch.
Melken?
Der kleine Biohof
ist Teil eines Konzepts.
Sie arbeiten eng
mit Rebecca Clopath zusammen,
Landwirtschaft und Gastronomie
verbinden sich.
Für mich ist es gesunder,
weil es gesamthaft gesünder ist.
Der Kreislauf,
den wir zu erwirtschaften versuchen,
ist gesund.
Das Tier ist gesund, der Boden
ist gesund, die Umwelt ist gesund.
Ich würde nicht sagen,
unsere Milch sei besser,
weil sie bio ist
und die Tiere Hörner haben,
als sonst eine, die an
einem anderen Ort produziert wird.
Es ist möglich, aber ich
überlasse es der Wissenschaft.
Für mich ist das Gesunde
auch das Ganze.
Die Produkte,
die wir hier produzieren können,
werden von Rebecca
zusätzlich veredelt.
Wir führen die Produkte
durch die Mägen hinweg.
Ich finde, so kann man
die grösste Wertschöpfung
in diesen Strukturen behalten
und das entsprechend auch vermarkten
oder verkaufen,
sodass es wieder interessanter wird.
Aber klar, ich meine, es ist ...
Wir verdienen uns
keine goldene Nase.
Es ist eine Herzenssache
und es ist ein Lebensstil,
den wir leben können
und der uns das alles wert ist.
Das ist der Rahm,
den Dominique mir gebracht hat.
Ich erhitze ihn auf 85 °C.
Wenn der Rahm die Temperatur
erreicht hat,
gebe ich verdünnte Weinsteinsäure
dazu.
Das ist das, was sich
in den Weinfässern absetzt.
Das kann man mörsern
und als Säure brauchen.
Dadurch bekommt der Rahm
einen Schock.
Die enthaltenen Proteine
denaturieren sich,
das gibt einen Schock.
Dann lassen wir das abhängen -
und das ist Mascarpone.
So einfach geht das.
* Brutzeln *
Auch durch.
* Wecker *
Wenn ich esse,
nehme ich immer etwas auf.
Viele Geschmäcker
sind bei mir im Kopf, im Gaumen.
Ich stelle mir einfach vor,
dass es zusammenpassen muss.
Dann kommt es auf den Tisch
und wenn es wirklich passt,
ist es umso schöner.
Hast du Leisten ...
- Ja, irgendwo sind die.
Und zwar ...
"Ausstecher". Ich glaube,
sie sind da drin oder da.
Ah, wow! Hier hinten
müsst ihr nicht filmen.
Das ist unsere Rumpelkammer.
Im Moment haben wir
diese zwei Herdplatten.
Der Rest
geschieht draussen auf dem Feuer.
Man arbeitet mit dem, was man hat.
Es ist erstaunlich.
Je mehr man hat,
desto mehr braucht man.
Man sieht, wie die Milch, der Rahm,
schon gestockt hat.
Das lassen wir 3-4 Std. abhängen.
* Piepsen *
* Sphärische Klänge *
(Brombach) In den letzten 50 Jahren
hat sich das Ernährungssystem
extrem verändert.
Immer wenn es eine Bewegung gibt,
gibt es auch Gegenbewegungen.
Eine Gegenbewegung z.B.
gegen bestimmte Formen
der Anonymität.
Man will wissen, woher das Essen
kommt, wer es hergestellt hat.
Eine Gegenbewegung auch
gegen Gleichförmigkeit
und Standardisierung.
Man möchte wieder zurückkommen
auf Eigenproduktion.
Man macht etwas selbst oder
setzt sich mit anderen zusammen
und produziert gemeinsam.
Oder auch Verunsicherung
als Ausdruck
eines allgemeinen Unbehagens.
Und das eigentlich bei uns
zu einer Zeit,
in der wir, wie noch nie
in der Menschheitsgeschichte
so viele sichere, hochqualitative
Lebensmittel haben.
Das ist eigentlich paradox.
Selbst wir als Experten -
wer von uns kann tatsächlich
bei dem Riesenangebot,
das wir im Detailhandel haben ...
Ich spreche hier
von durchschnittlich
20'000-30'000 Artikeln.
Wer kann das
noch alles nachverfolgen?
Und zwar auf der Zutatenebene,
auf der Produktionsebene,
auf der Auswirkungsebene -
das ist unmöglich.
Das macht uns
im wahrsten Sinne verrückt,
weil es zu viel ist.
Und was machen wir,
wenn etwas zu viel ist?
Wir ziehen uns auf das zurück,
was wir vermeintlich überschauen
und kontrollieren können.
"Der Teller ist rund",
sagt man so schön.
Auf dieser Scheibe legt man fest,
was für sich überschaubar bleibt
und dort kreiert man seine Welt.
* Rockige Klänge *
* Er keucht. *
* Ächzen *
Ausserhalb der veganen Bewegung
hat man das Bild
eines dürren, blassen,
unsportlichen Menschen im Kopf,
der mit selbst gestrickten
Baumwollsocken herumläuft.
Ein typischer Hippie.
Als ich diese Sportler-Community
gründete, war mir wichtig,
dieses Bild etwas zu zerstören
und zu zeigen:
"Wenn dir Sport wichtig ist,
wenn dir Körperkult wichtig ist,
dann kannst du das komplett
ohne Tierausbeutung praktizieren."
Ich betreibe
seit 17 Jahren Kraftsport.
Ich trainiere jetzt
nicht mehr als vorher.
Der Körper
hat sich verändert im Sinn von:
Ich bin lustigerweise
muskulöser geworden.
Das Argument, bei veganer Ernährung
zu wenig Proteine zu haben,
trifft bei mir nicht zu.
Und ich bin definierter.
Hier steht der Beweis,
der sich komplett pflanzlich
aufgebaut hat.
Du hast 30 kg zugenommen.
- Genau.
Wie viele Beweise braucht man noch?
Besonders bei diesem schweren Jungen
ist es allerspätestens vorbei
mit den Mythen.
Er beweist uns allen hier,
dass es pflanzlich funktioniert.
Und, warum eigentlich nicht?
Wenn man logisch überlegt,
sind die besten
bio-verfügbaren Aminosäuren
nur in pflanzlicher Form.
Die stärksten Tiere der Welt -
ein Gorilla, ein Pferd, ein Stier -
nehmen auch nur Pflanzen zu sich.
Es sind die stärksten
und intelligentesten Tiere.
Wer das immer noch nicht glaubt,
kann uns gerne auf Instagram
oder Facebook folgen.
Dort sieht man unseren Lifestyle,
was wir zu uns nehmen,
wie wir uns ernähren.
* Pulsierende Musik *
In dieser Bewegung gibt es manche,
die noch weitergehen.
Er ernährt sich nur von Rohkost.
Zuvor lebte ich fünf Jahre vegan.
Ich merkte:
Je mehr Rohkost ich einbaue,
umso schneller
geht meine Regeneration,
kann ich wieder trainieren
und umso klarer werde ich.
Das war nicht nur eine körperliche,
sondern auch
ein geistige Entwicklung.
Ich habe immer versucht,
das Beste aus mir herauszuholen.
Immer optimieren, in dem Sinn
immer noch einfacher zu leben,
sodass mein Körper umso besser
mit einfachsten Lebensmitteln
optimal funktionieren kann.
Ohne Verarbeitung, einfach so,
wie die Natur es gibt.
Treibhausware, Chemikalien,
Wasserverbrauch, Verpackungen,
Arbeitsbedingungen.
Unser Konsum schafft Probleme.
Da haben wir die bösen zwei
gleich nebeneinander.
Man sieht es: Die sind aus dem
Treibhaus und sind nicht ganz reif.
Aber wenn man daran riecht, muss man
sagen, dass die Ware lässig ist.
Ich muss es
nicht zwingend verkaufen.
Mir macht es keine Freude,
emotional sagt mir das nicht zu.
Aber man hat es halt im Angebot.
Es ist ein heikles Thema. Welches
Produkt ist böse, welches nicht?
Wir sind keine Heiligen.
Das ist ganz wichtig:
In dieser Branche sind wir alle
ein Teil des Problems.
Wir sind ein Grosshandel und damit
ein grosser Teil des Problems.
Das klingt negativ,
aber das ist die Realität,
da muss man ehrlich sein.
Die Frage ist,
was wir besser machen können.
* Treibende Gitarrenklänge *
Wir gehen zu Doris und Thomas Käser
in Birmensdorf.
Sie sind für uns
sehr wichtig für Salat.
Sie sind keine Grossproduzenten,
aber auch keine Kleinen.
Sie gehören auch zu denen, die immer
neue Sachen auf den Markt bringen.
Das ist mir wichtig.
Sie suchen immer nach Neuem.
Was heute während des Tages
geerntet wird,
geht am Abend zu uns in die Markt-
halle und morgen in die Gastronomie.
Da sind die kurzen Wege von Vorteil.
Und man kann es verkaufen.
Regionalität
ist ein Verkaufsargument.
Wenn es so ist,
weshalb soll man es nicht machen?
Marinello setzt auf Regionalität.
Denn regionale Produkte
stehen bei Schweizer Konsumentinnen
und Konsumenten hoch im Kurs.
Hoi, Tiziano.
- Hoi.
Diese Salatmischung produzieren
Käsers exklusiv für Marinello.
Das ist immer noch Topqualität.
Eigentlich ist die Saison vorbei.
Da haben wir Tatsoi,
das ist roter Tatsoi.
Dann hast du Mizuna.
Immer noch fein. Wollen wir wirklich
in den nächsten Tagen aufhören?
Er ist noch so schön.- Von mir aus
können wir weitermachen.
Kai sagte,
es gebe nach wie vor solche,
die noch Einheimischen wollen.
- Das Gefühl habe ich auch.
Wir haben noch
und die Qualität ist im Herbst
mit den kühleren Temperaturen ...
Die Blätter sind viel knackiger.
Superschön.
- Auch gesunder.
Da wechseln wir zu einem Produzenten
in Norditalien, im Veneto.
Nun haben wir diese Situation.
Wir haben abgemacht,
in den nächsten Tagen zu wechseln.
Es sieht so aus ...
Ich würde lieber
noch das hier verkaufen.
Aber das weiss man nie.
Man hat auf der anderen Seite
einen Partner, einen Importeur,
der auf das Volumen angewiesen ist.
Man muss einen Mittelweg finden.
Meistens geht das gut.
Es ist wichtig, dass wir uns
untereinander absprechen
und Erfahrungswerte haben.
Andere Abnehmer sagen mir:
"Morgen ist fertig."
Mhm.
- Ja.
Es wäre wünschenswert,
wenn allgemein die Zusammenarbeit
und die Absprachen
mehr stattfinden würden.
Dieses Produkt ist hier ein anderes
als bei mir im Lager.
Es ist emotional anders,
wenn ich es bei euch sehe,
als wenn ich es bei mir
an Lager habe -
auch wenn es dieselbe Kiste wäre.
* Schleppende Gitarrenklänge *
* Knistern, Stimmengewirr *
Für diesen Film lassen sich Christine
Brombach und Tiziano Marinello
auf eine Esswahrnehmung ein.
Der Anlass
wird mehrere Stunden dauern.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Wir sind vollständig.
Ich bin hier aufgewachsen,
da oben war mein Kinderzimmer.
Wir verzichten bewusst auf Kaffee,
Schokolade, Zimt, Nelken, Vanille -
alles, was von weit her kommt.
Es geht nicht darum,
etwas zu verpönen
oder die Globalisierung
schlechtzureden.
Es geht nur darum, euch zu zeigen,
wie vielfältig der alpine Raum ist,
dass ich euch meine Heimat
auf den Teller bringen kann,
dass man den Geschmack der Alpen
wahrnehmen kann,
ohne dass etwas von irgendwo
fremdbeeinflusst ist.
Wunderbar.
Schön, seid ihr dabei. Merci.
Auf den ersten Blick
könnte man denken,
es sei esoterisch angehaucht -
mit dieser Wahrnehmung.
Kommt der Genuss nicht zu kurz?
Ich habe schon viel
von Rebecca gehört und gelesen.
Ich bin einfach total gespannt.
(Clopath) Wir können loslegen, go.
Wir starten auch bei euch
mit einem Gänse-Consommée.
Das ist eine doppelt-geklärte
Kraftbrühe.
Aus der Gans
haben wir noch Rillettes gemacht,
dazu Quitten, Bohnenkraut
und Lorbeer.
Alles in einem Cornet
aus Farina Bona,
einem gerösteten Maismehl
aus dem Tessin.
Viel Spass.
Mmh!
- Sie sagte, das sei Gans, oder?
Doppelt. Doppeltes Consommé.
Mmh!
Wahnsinnig intensiv
und reichhaltig im Mund.
Richtiges Seelenkraftfutter. Ja?
Die Farbe ist schön braun,
dunkel, karamellig.
Es braucht viel Handwerk,
so etwas hinzukriegen.
Ich habe gemerkt,
dass mir das Übliche
in der Gastronomie nicht entspricht.
Das liegt wohl daran,
dass ich schon die Lehre
an einem unüblichen Ort gemacht
und auch lange an einem
unüblichen Ort gearbeitet habe.
Ich bin an einem
eher unüblichen Ort aufgewachsen
und meine Mutter
nannte mich immer Rebell.
Dort, wo es mich interessiert,
gehe ich hin.
* Muntere, zuckende Gitarrenklänge *
* Surren *
* Lachen *
(Brombach) Danke schön.
Mmh.
Ich hatte noch nie
fermentierten Mangold.
Im Nachgang schmeckt man
die Schärfe des Ingwer.
Ein neues Menü
braucht immer sehr viel Zeit.
Es ist nicht nur das Essen,
das man bereitmachen muss.
Es ist viel Research mit den
Geschichten, die dahinter sind.
Man kocht nicht alles an einem Tag.
Es gibt Sachen,
die brauchen 12 Std., drei Wochen,
fünf Monate, zwei Jahre.
(Brombach) Auch der Sellerie ...
- Grossartig.
Ich sprach am Anfang von Esoterik,
aber diese Wahrnehmung
hat mich schon voll gepackt.
Es ist auch lässig mit der Säure,
mit ...
Es ist sehr mutig gesalzen,
es ist kräftig.
Ich spüre den Waldboden
unter meinen Füssen.
(Brombach) Ich würde schon sagen,
dass es ein Spiegelbild ist.
Das Essen, das Essverhalten
sagt etwas über die Art
der Gesellschaft aus.
Ich kann nicht mehr
einfach nur etwas essen,
es muss auch etwas aussagen,
es muss etwas mit mir machen.
So esse ich und so bin ich.
Das ist die Murmeltierwurst.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Yes, merci.
(Rebecca) Wenn es etwas gibt,
das ihr nicht mögt,
lasst ihr es weg,
denn euer Körper möchte das nicht.
Darum geht es eigentlich.
Was finde ich eigentlich sehr schön,
was mag ich
und was möchte ich
auf meinem Teller haben?
Was ist das?
- Koriander.
Ich glaube,
da bin ich etwas vorsichtig.
Entweder man mag es
oder man mag es nicht.
Wir kommen wieder
auf diese Erkenntnisse zurück,
dass es tatsächlich Dinge gibt,
die für den einen besser,
für den anderen weniger gut sind.
Eigentlich wollen wir zurück
in diese Balance, in diese Harmonie.
Danach sehnen wir uns auch zutiefst.
* Gezupfte Gitarrenklänge *
Ernährung als Sehnsuchtsort.
In einer Welt, die unsicher
und kompliziert geworden ist.
Eine Welt, die uns
ein Angebot bietet wie nie zuvor.
Und uns hier den Luxus ermöglicht,
zu entscheiden,
was auf unsere Teller kommt.
Ich fühle mich leicht,
ich fühle mich nicht beschwert.
Häufig hat man nach einem opulenten
Essen so ein "Och"-Gefühl,
Das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen -
ich fühle mich fit.
Ich habe mich selbst wahrgenommen,
was schön ist.
Es waren
viele vertraute Geschmäcker dabei.
Natürlich - es war komplex, es gab
viele Gänge mit vielen Komponenten.
Aber die Karotte
schmeckte wie eine Karotte,
das Feuer roch nach Feuer,
man fühlte sich wie ein Pfadfinder
und erinnerte sich
an ursprüngliche Dinge.
Es machte unglaublich Spass.
* Lockere Gitarrenklänge,
vereinzelte Klaviertöne *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Andrea Werlen - 2020